keep in mind tonight biden is battling
numerous self-inflicted crisis at home
and abroad now the administration plans
to accept exempt some
afghans that served that were the old
taliban government he's going to take
them there are no lists he's going to
lift the no-fly list in other words let
them come into america did they change
their values all of a sudden against
this radical sharia law that they
imposed on the people when they were in
charge of the islamic emirates of
afghanistan and meanwhile biden's
special envoy is now warning that the
u.s must accept and prepare for a fully
nuclear iran you mean the people that
chant death to america death to israel
we're going to let them get nuclear
weapons and we're okay with that
and joe's defense department intel
community had no clue apparently
whatsoever about china's new hypersonic
weapons that can deliver nuclear weapons
they they welcome the stiff competition
and biden's silence on china's repeated
quote reunification or takeover or
really threats with taiwan it's been
deafening and joe has not lifted a
finger to help taiwan in stopping china
and their invasion of taiwan airspace
with their fighter jets day and night
here with reaction all of that former
secretary of state mike pompeo who's
speaking with us by the way near the uss
midway in san diego uh great to see you
mr secretary well it's
66 days now americans trapped behind
enemy lines let's start with the china
question first then we'll go to iran
then we'll go to afghanistan on china's
clear
uh uh political ambitions to reunify
with taiwan joe biden's not lifting a
finger what should he be doing
what we did for four years sean was make
clear to the people of taiwan that we'd
be there to support them to provide what
they needed so they could defend
themselves and we made clear to the
chinese communist party that it was
completely unacceptable if they took
military action against the island of
taiwan those two basic facts were things
president trump was very clear he was
prepared to defend they could see that
we did that elsewhere in the world when
we struck qasim sulaimani when we fired
rockets into syria when they used
chemical weapons crossing president
trump's red line i think they all knew
that we were serious about protecting
americans i think they realize that
the debacle in afghanistan the fact the
iranians fired missiles from the gaza
strip into israel have all shown
american weakness and i see that the
four things you walked through tonight
those are all things where america is
showing weakness and when you do that
our adversaries will do everything they
can to put us at risk and to crush us
well and i didn't even mention the
russia part now let me go to the iranian
part
if in fact you marry
this this death to america death to
israel
mantra or convert or die mantra of the
iranian muellers and you empower them
with nuclear weapons which now the biden
administration is signaling i guess
they're going to be that they'll accept
uh what is the risk to the world at that
point because to me it seems very real
because i imagine that the muellers
might be thinking they're doing god's
will by firing that weapon at either
israel or the u.s or another country
i can't believe they're going to permit
this to happen president biden is on
record multiple times saying he will
never permit iran to have a nuclear
weapon i saw what what robert malley the
special envoy began to signal if you're
the israelis
you know that you can't live with an
iran with a nuclear weapon i must say
this this puts them at real risk it puts
the whole world at risk that they'll
proliferate these very nuclear weapons
right it may not be the case that
they'll fire them they could distribute
them iran is known for selling weapons
all across the world
this is a very serious matter we we were
determined uh we we delivered putting
the harshest sanctions on the ayatollah
and his henchmen that iran had ever seen
we had isolated them we built up
friendships with the israelis the
abraham accords brought the gulf states
alongside of us this is how you deter
aggression allowing iran to get a
nuclear weapon puts our partner and
friend israel at risk it puts the gulf
at risk it creates risk for the united
states of america as well
let me bounce back to china because i
meant to ask you about this hypersonic
weapon apparently the biden
administration didn't see it coming the
defense
department didn't see it coming their
intel community didn't see it coming not
only did they that not only are they
shoving it in our face
they're capable apparently of of
launching nuclear weapons with this new
technology
can you could what would now the bite
administration said they welcomed stiff
competition to me that is a clear and
present danger to the united states of
america
uh the the the fact that they claim they
welcome stiff consciousness is just so
odd to say about the chinese communist
party these aren't these aren't
competitors this is an adversary who has
made clear they want the world to look
like their marxist leninist ideological
world
now this capability that flies at
multiples of the speed of sound that's
what hypersonic translates into
is very difficult to defend against the
united states under president obama did
nothing to build out defensive systems
we began that work we began to build out
our own set of capabilities this is this
is really important the fact that the
chinese now can deliver at least the
missile component of this program to
within a couple of dozen miles think
think how big los angeles is right to
within a couple of dozen miles of the
target is a serious matter and one that
our department of defense and the
president himself must take seriously
begin to respond to not by claiming they
welcome that kind of step competition
that's just that's just crazy
79 days ago joe biden said he wouldn't
leave a single american behind in
afghanistan 66 days ago he abandoned
americans their families thousands of
green card holders and tens of thousands
of our afghan allies he hasn't mentioned
any of them in 49 days
do you have any hope outside of outside
groups or joe biden's plan to bribe the
islamic emirates of afghanistan to get
our people back
sadly i'm counting on outside groups
private citizens i've been working with
some trying to make sure we get every
last american out of there i hope the
government will do their share but
there's no evidence they're prepared to
do that sean
never thought i'd see that mr secretary
in my lifetime never thought i'd see
americans abandoned behind terrorist
lines after a president promises he
wouldn't do it thank you for being with
us sir we appreciate it hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else